[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
essentially they're very expensive
action figures all of the limbs fingers
joints move and that's because inside we
have an armature it's a skeleton
essentially the stop motion technique
involves taking one frame of film and
there are 24 frames for every second of
finished film and in the most basic
sense if they want something to move
slowly they move it a small amount like
that and if they want to look fast then
they'll move it the big stop motion by
it very nature stops action and it can
look a bit kind of jittery and jumping
but in this scene we wanted the action
be frantic and phonetic the rigging
Department came up with this amazing
solution they attached a little rig on
kind of rotating wires so just a hand
drill
[Music]
massive elation because you've achieved
something that at the beginning actually
seems almost impossible when you set out
to make a movie like this and I think
it's the same for any big project you
kind of almost can't see the end and you
don't know quite how you're gonna do it
know it possible and you know that
there's enthusiasm and you're up for the
challenge
but when you actually get to the end it
it is amazing
[Music]
you
[Music]